hello and welcome to another episode of
footnotes my name is Matt Simon as per
the usual I am here to recap the most
ravishing language and ideas from the
last week of wired first up today we're
going to help or at least the edges of
it why business reporter last week on
YouTube starting to ask its commenters
to use their real names in an effort to
civilize what has long been the most
vile vicious sexist racist anti-semitic
and anti intellectual sounding board on
the Internet
no one is safe on YouTube unless of
course it happens to be opposite day the
article refers to the YouTube commenting
system as a Hellmouth of crude abuse a
Hellmouth being an entrance to the
underworld that is literally the mouth
of some giant Beast
this concept was invented by the
anglo-saxons and remained popular in art
throughout the Middle Ages often used as
a prop in theatrical performances
directors got away with tossing their
performers into a toothy pit because
back then there were no unions and no
OSHA it should be noted that the
hellmouth's didn't actually chew their
food since 1 October mostly intact in
order to burn properly in hell this begs
the question of why artists included
teeth at all and the answer to that is
that teeth are fairly easy to drop and
that without them the monsters would
just look like giant toads and that's
not very scary as the Middle Ages waned
the idea of being eaten and Burnie
fraternity was replaced with just
burning for eternity perhaps the
monsters just weren't hungry anymore
moving on from fire and brimstone let's
go to the heavens in a Wired science
recap of the physical and mental
oddities the astronauts experienced
while in orbit reporter Adam man makes
mention of the overview effect this term
was coined by author Frank white to
describe the overwhelming sense of awe
and serenity that strikes astronauts as
they do the earth they suddenly
understand the fragility of our planet
and the absurdity of human conflict and
international boundaries which is a
somewhat inconsiderate position for
those who make a living by
jailing people who legally cross
national borders there's actually an
organization called the overview
Institute whose goal is to expose as
many people as possible to the overview
effect this they argue will help blow us
out of our catastrophic dealings with
our planet and each other kind of like
kony2012 tried to do only this time in a
less sketchy and irresponsible manner
this will be expensive so we should
carefully choose who we decide to expose
to the overview effect we could start
for example by firing people like Kony
into a brief but enlightening orbit then
have them land back on earth and it
convincingly constructed Hellmouth
packed with space heaters at this point
they'll be really scared and
uncomfortably warm so they'll ask us to
fire them back into orbit where we will
leave them indefinitely with fewer
warlords and dictators will no longer
need contentious video campaigns like
Kony 2012 thus restoring YouTube to
civility except of course on opposite
day
you